cuando menos te lo esperas la vida
de las sorpresas
tal como dice la canción
y esas sorpresas solamente te dieran
hacerte preguntas y tienes intrigas
al saber el cielo y le preguntas del
señor
lo hago
estoy preparado
vale la pena hacerlo
voy a entregar
no voy a fracasar
y claro tú te quedas con la intriga qué
pasa
y ahora
vecinas
dudas
y noches
todos
una decisión que no no
nueva delhi
pérez a
louis
dios
sí
todos
[Música]
bien
cree él
yo creo
y creo en mí
pero también creo en los que están cerca
de mí
los que están lejos de mí
de amigos en los que no son mis amigos
en todos ellos
la historia comienza
cuando yo tenía apenas 21 años de edad
tomé la decisión
la decisión era salir del país
irme a buscar nuevas fronteras
a buscar las oportunidades
la reuniã mi papá mi mamá
[Música]
mi padre sabio me dijo
de apoyo de la bendición y demás mi
madre
el afecto el amor un abrazo un beso una
lágrima
y la frase
y ese día la decisión estaba tomada
en mi mente me voy pero queda van a
traer recuerdos
mi comida en versión cultura
en él
hoy en verdad
también diré más para los rosas que
tenían
sobrevivir
entonces
no necesitaba
aparecimos un barrio donde el mismo
aunque
y bien siempre están contratando a gente
y me fui entonces
era otra decisión
dije que vivir
hay que hacer algo para poder sobrevivir
recuerdo que entré a la fábrica me
dijeron bienvenido y me trajo el niño de
la fábrica manager y me dijo un
trapeador me trajo
me dijo de hoy en adelante este es su
mejor amigo y vas a barrer toda la
fábrica tenía ocho horas para barrer una
fábrica inmensa
y entonces berria
y después me dijo si ves alguna rata la
matas
ok
yo les tenía miedo a las ratas
y entonces empecé a barrer y en los 10
metros la primera
y yo con que le mató con tu mejor amigo
entonces bueno vamos a matar y perseguir
a las ratas hasta matarla a la final
terminaba matando a los cientes ratas
por día
entonces aprendí
a focalizar
a enfocarme
a saber que esas cosas que pasaban tenía
que aprender a valorar
porque había dejado atrás una vida que
tenía casi hecha
pero adelante tenía otro objetivo el que
me puse en meses atrás cuando aquí en
ecuador toma la decisión
y me fui
dirección en mi mente hacia lo que
quería
y no era fácil
pasaron seis meses de otro amigo me dijo
mira hay una fábrica donde tienes que
poner broches de las camisas es fácil
vamos vamos
normalmente otra decisión
y esa decisión me hacía perseverante esa
decisión
me decía que vaya buscando otras cosas
a lo mejor más difíciles
en mi mente decían robert trabajar
búscate algo mejor es una cosa es otra
cosa
bueno entre tantas cosas logré conseguir
los contactos de los medios de
comunicación más importantes a la ciudad
donde yo débil era la gran manzana
ni
garcía
y
1 día
pero yo ahí
luchando perseveran
había que sobrevivir
y seguía trabajando y mientras esto
pasaba yo entraba a otro lugar de
trabajo tomaban paredes lavaba platos
entre hojas volantes en las esquinas
en las paradas de los trenes
todo mi grande pasadores
todo ser humano tiene que aprender a
caminar en cualquier terreno que nos
toque hacerlo
con humildad
y no agacha la cabeza porque me sentía
rendido
en la tabla cabeza porque valoraba el
plato de comida
y que vaya
esas cosas valoraba y empezaba a
aprender de la vida
esta vida que es hermoso
y entonces el esfuerzo se fue
convirtiendo en una tarea diaria
y el trabajo cambiaba a lo mejor en un
día en un lugar que tenía una semana y
después me decían gracias
y después del sábado y domingo tenía que
buscar otro lugar
y encima buscaba
y era esfuerzo y más esfuerzo y eran
luchas conmigo con interior y después
tenía que salir adelante había que comer
y yo decía hasta cuándo
todo estaba en la mente pero también en
el cuerpo porque el esfuerzo era físico
ya no hacía lo que hacía antes en
ecuador'
estaba haciendo cosas distintas miami
desgaste era más físico que mental
pero en la mente siempre el objetivo
cuatro años más tarde de esos trabajos
de esfuerzo
mientras yo conducía un bus de pasajeros
había obtenido ya la licencia de manejo
no sabía hablar inglés todavía
bien
para la gente
i
me iba
más
nada
e
no es así
ni
y vamos a salir y al mundo
[Música]
de vido
bien
vemos
y en él
y de ahí
d
los padres de nuevos el alcance de todos
llegué a la casa y les conté a los
amigos que vivían en esa misma casa y
ellos eran norteamericanos
se mataban de la risa
me decían qué bruto que eres estaba
pidiendo en cinco dólares devuelto no te
estaba pidiendo que te des los cinco yo
rojo de vergüenza aprendí la primera
lección
en inglés
tenía que aprender a hablar ese idioma
porque si no no podía hacer
estaba en una tierra donde el lenguaje y
el idioma principal era hablar inglés yo
no saben
volví a tomar la decisión
y dije hasta aquí llegó el español eso
de atrás es historia
entonces
mientras esto ocurría un viernes a las 6
de la tarde
después de haber trabajado 18 horas
conduciendo el bus y regresaba a mi casa
idea o anuncio se enseña inglés
también nuevamente la decisión dije
ahora es cuando había reunido ya un poco
de dinero el trabajo que tenía me
permitía silencio
qué va a pasar conmigo de sí
otra decisión
nunca
quite el objetivo que me había puesto en
cabeza y para esto ya habían pasado años
rendirme
seguía luchando
master link
cuatro meses después de tomar clases dos
horas diarias con un activo de ella
logré aprender a hablar inglés
y mi vida cambió
porque me olvidé del español para poder
ir amos que el trabajo
esa era la salida
es en el camino que yo debía seguir
y lo dicen
en una empresa financiera que me
contrató para estar
insertando en el sistema valores de
cheques tenía que pasar ocho horas
sentado sentado sin poder ir al baño
a veces no comía pero tenía que hacer
un día dije que hay que trabajar
y según
entonces bienvenido
e
hoy
y sin ninguno
t
m
en esta semana
la lista de los vientos
10 9 8
y en ese punto
y
la segunda de cinco
así
bien estado
no quieras
pero soy yo
me había preparado
avn terminado en la universidad acá ya
era un periodista
y entonces este colombiano me dijo
si mañana te llaman a las seis de la
mañana / al narrador
no te atrevas a llamar
esa noche no dormí no puse el teléfono
sobre mi pecho llamé a todos mis amigos
para ver si sonaba duro el teléfono para
ver si funcionaba a las seis de la
mañana timbre
y el susto de mi vida salté como resorte
corrí al comedor estaba en las hojas y
leí las noticias
la voz femenina que estaba en otra
nadadora la productora general entiende
me dijo robert bienvenido a la cadena
eres el nuevo corresponsal
era el sueño hecho realidad
era el cambio de vida era la llamada
perfecta era una decisión que había
tomado
a una nueva oportunidad
me esforcé
y lograba dar el primer paso
eran largos días porque trabajaba
durante el día en un lugar y en la noche
daba las noticias para la radio
después dije que bueno
un amigo me dijo te encargó este fin de
semana una agencia donde
tienes algo que recoger los papeles de
la gente que viene aquí se hacen las
declaraciones de impuestos income tax
[Música]
yo le dije aunque my friend a wikileaks
ese día
domingo 6 de la tarde tiene una señora
con una barriga
estaba a punto de dar a luz entrega los
papeles llenó los formularios y mientras
se hacían las preguntas de rutina
te digo profesión me dice el periodista
y yo le abrí los ojos así
y me dice y tú que eres medio también
soy periodista
venciendo medidas saben ser noticias por
supuesto
ni
[Música]
ideal
y entonces
y en los mismos
no
y
d
todos nosotros
luz
[Música]
no no
después su persona
entonces en el limón
los mismos
[Música]
pero sí que sí
y en dos
aprendí a hacer este periodismo humano
me preguntaba y ahora yo que hago bien
pasados 12 años
[Música]
y un día dije bueno
cumplí con el sueño americano porque el
sueño americano para mí no era quedarme
a vivir era lograr llegar hacia la meta
que me había puesto y lo logré
me hizo feliz
me hizo volver a ser yo
si ustedes creen
luchen cree en ustedes
hagan las cosas con esfuerzo
si luchan como decía bertol brecht y
este poeta alemán hay hombres que luchan
un día y son buenos hay hombres que
luchan un año y son mejores hay unos que
luchan muchos años y son muy buenos pero
hay hombres que luchan toda la vida esos
son los imprescindibles pero harán no
todo con amor porque si lo hacen con
amor ustedes van a vencer van a triunfar
y van a ser unos hermosos seres humanos
[Aplausos]